[Music]
the year 2020 meant different things to
different people
for many it was a very difficult year
the lockdown to me was a chance to gain
some perspective
i realized that i was stuck in a rut in
my career and i wanted to break out of
it
so i took the full stack java developer
masters program from simply learn to
up-skill and went from being a junior
business analyst to a software developer
with an 80 salary hike
hi my name is omkar and i am a software
developer at zeo mega after over a year
in my previous job i personally felt
that i was not growing to my full
potential many a times i had to take
help from other experts while writing
the course because i was not able to do
it myself so when i decided to up skill
i specifically wanted java cores that
would help me to become a
self-sufficient software developer
while comparing e-learning platforms i
saw that simplylearn had a job guarantee
program once the course was over
i was getting 10 to 15 callbacks for
interviews in a single week
the response of the support team was
very quick and the trainers were also
very experienced during the interview i
found out that i was able to fit in most
of the roles perfectly because all my
key responsibilities were very well
covered in the course
i am very pleased with the turn that my
career has taken apart from getting a
job i am very much confident with my
abilities as a software developer and i
would like to thank simply learn for
that if there is one thing we all must
learn from my experience is that we must
never settle
don't go through life but grow through
it because growth cannot be locked down